We're all in this together
Once we know
That we are
We're all stars
And we see that
Aww yeah! What's up everybody? Today you're learning
English with the classic High School Musical!
And don't worry if you haven't
seen the movie or if you are not a fan of musicals,
because this lesson will help you on your dream
to be able to understand TV Series and movies
without getting lost, without
missing the jokes and without subtitles.
In fact, Pedro wrote to us and he
told us that after watching our channel
and learning from our lessons he can now understand
conversations and watch movies without subtitles.
So, join Pedro and improve your English!
All you need to do is hit that subscribe button and the bell
down below so you don’t miss any of our new lessons!
So, in this example, the commercial
has made the same joke as Troy.
And that's really the great thing about Learning with Friends.
You learn real-life vocabulary to understand jokes.
You can study and have fun at the same time!
And I will let you try our Fluent with Friends
course for FREE today with our 3 part master class.
To get started and sign up today you can click up here, or
I'll leave a link to download in the description below.
What are you waiting for?
Now, do you have the impression
that English speakers speak "fast"?
Maybe because when you read you can understand everything
but then when you listen it's like a whole different language?
What you may think is "fast English"
is what we call connected speech.
So, when we use connected speech we cut, link and connect words
together to make speech more natural and easier.
So, I guess the important thing to
remember about connected speech is that
not all words in English are said with the same
speed, the same rhythm and the same length.
I hope you enjoyed learning with High School
Musical today. And before you watch without subtitles
and test your knowledge with a quiz, make
sure you run over to our Instagram
at RealLife.English to stay informed and updated about
all the lessons we have on our 2 YouTube Channels
and our Podcast. Aww yeah!